today i want to talk about the most important
things you need to know if you have acid reflux so
i have this diagram of the stomach there's a valve
on the top part and there's a valve on the lower
part the valve on the top prevents acid
and food from regurgitating up through
the esophagus the valve in the bottom
controls the food from the stomach
into the small intestine as well as controlling
the food and bile from regurgitating back up into
the stomach so both of these valves are sphincters
it's like a circular muscle that is controlled by
the autonomic nervous system so the muscular
control is kind of a gradual contraction and
a gradual relaxation until it's fully open and so
the problem we have with these valves is they're
if they're open at the wrong time or close at the
wrong time we can have a big problem with acid
and bile ending up in the wrong place now because
they're controlled by the autonomic nervous system
that means that they're highly influenced with
this thing called stress and this is why there are
so many digestive problems that can be affected
by stress like acid reflux heartburn and the list
goes on and on and on and so if you have acid
reflux and a lot of stress you know you're gonna
have to do something to reduce that stress before
it starts improving now the other thing that
controls these sphincters is calcium calcium has
the function of muscular contraction so it helps
close these sphincters but most of the time people
are lacking the vitamin that controls calcium
i'm talking about vitamin d if you're deficient in
vitamin d you're not going to have enough calcium
and the valve is not going to close fully and
incidentally vitamin d also acts like cortisol in
the body and there's a lot to do with controlling
stress and by taking vitamin d that can actually
help reduce your stress and can help directly
close the valve just from the function of vitamin
d itself now the other cause of this valve on
the top of the stomach opening at the wrong time
is because you don't have enough hydrochloric acid
in your stomach apparently there are receptors or
sensors in that valve for hydrochloric acid
so we have the synchronization of food coming
through the valve closing and acid increasing so
you can get a complete digestion so if you don't
have enough hydrochloric acid or the acid in your
stomach is not acid enough that valve might not
close and that can cause the regurgitation effect
so what can cause a deficiency of hydrochloric
acid well one is low chlorides as in low salt
so if you're on a low salt diet or not taking
enough sea salt that could be the reason
why you don't have enough hydrochloric acid
also it takes potassium to also make hydrochloric
acid so you need those electrolytes as the
building blocks to make hydrochloric acid now
another big cause of low hydrochloric acid is
medication induced hypochlorhydria that
is low stomach acid caused by antacids
especially the ppis now there are also foods that
actually can aggravate the situation gluten grains
sugar of course alcohol and omega-6 fatty acids
as in all the soy oil the canola oil the corn oil
the cottonseed oil and of course all
the processed foods and the junk foods
those can not only disrupt the opening closing
of the valves but they can also disrupt the
production of hydrochloric acid let me first
talk about the importance of hydrochloric acid
okay number one its role in intestinal
hormones you have all sorts of hormones
that are involved in your digestion and your small
intestine that's secreted from the pancreas that's
secreted from the small intestine itself and
without hydrochloric acid they can't work a lot
of the enzymes that are in the upper part of the
digestive system they're activated by a certain
ph hydrochloric acid being an acid activates these
enzymes so they can work all right number two hcl
prepares folate and b12 for absorption number
three hydrochloric acid helps the absorption of
minerals i'm talking about calcium magnesium
potassium zinc and iron all right number four
hydrochloric acid is also necessary for something
called the intrinsic factor for the absorption of
b12 another mechanism of b12 absorption if you
don't have enough b12 you're going to have a lot
of neurological problems and a lot of pain from
nerve damage all right next one is hcl is vital
in the prevention of small intestinal bacterial
overgrowth this is the prevention of bacteria
growing in the small intestine that's the wrong
place we want bacteria growing in the large
colon not the small intestine and so without
hydrochloric acid you can get sibo hcl is
vital in preventing pathogens microbes that are
unfriendly going through the stomach and invading
the body so we need this hydrochloric acid to kill
off unfriendly bacteria fungus viruses that are in
our foods and also hcl is vital in preventing food
allergies because we want to take this protein
break it down fully into amino acids and so if
it's not fully broken down your immune system
can react to it and you can develop allergies
all right so let me just touch briefly on the
valve on the bottom part of the stomach okay
and this valve is very important in preventing
bile from regurgitating up into the stomach and
then up into the esophagus bile can irritate
the esophagus just as much as hydrochloric acid
because it's a detergent and it can break down
the mucous layer and create a lot of pain and
irritation now there's three main culprits or
problems with that happening number one excess
belly fat if you have too much visceral fat
all that fat can put pressure up into this area
and cause a regurgitation of bile back up into
the stomach number two hiatal hernia and for more
information about that i put a video down below
so you can learn a real simple technique to
help that condition and lastly if you have a
gallbladder problem or you have bile sludge or
even gallstones that's obstructing the flow of
bile that can create a backup bile into the system
and the solution for that is purify bile salts all
right so what are the very important things
you need to do if you have acid reflux number
one i would recommend starting out taking the
tane hydrochloride methane hydrochloride is a
really good remedy for acid reflux it's going to
increase the concentration of acid in your stomach
and the problem with a lot of people when they
take obtain hydrochloride is they think that
one or two with a meal is going to solve it
usually they're going to need a lot more maybe
five six seven eight with a meal especially in
the beginning and you would want to take it right
before the meal and you'll see it'll create a huge
improvement in the digestion of your food and a
lessening of the backup of acid that's coming into
your esophagus also apple cider vinegar is very
very important to add with that and you'll find
great relief if you add both of those together now
if you're taking betaine heterochloride and apple
cider vinegar and you feel worse it aggravates the
problem that could mean you either have an ulcer
or gastritis in which case you need to switch your
plan of action and start taking chlorophyll
or some organic raw wheatgrass juice powder
so that can help heal the irritation in your
esophagus and your stomach the best vegetable
or even food for acid reflux is cabbage okay
all forms of cabbage and even sauerkraut so
make mental note of that all right number three
very important reduce your stress do whatever
you can to reduce your stress i have a thousand
videos on how to do that all right number four
intermittent fasting if you're consuming six
small meals or eating frequently just think
about what's happening you're stressing the entire
digestive system intermittent fasting the decrease
of frequency of eating especially if you can do
two meals or even one meal a day that's called
omad will greatly improve your acid reflux why
because it gives your digestive system a chance to
reset and heal and not work so hard all right
number five vitamin d i've already mentioned that
very important to prevent acid reflux number
six zinc l-carnosine is not only good for ulcers
gastritis it's also good for gerd and acid reflux
in fact zinc l-carnosine is good for anything
that's inflamed in your entire gastrointestinal
tract and number seven taking a very good
probiotic because if you have the microbes helping
you digest in the lower part of your your system
that'll take a huge stress off the top part of
the digestive system because they're all connected
alright thanks for watching and i will see
you in the next video hey before you go
if you're benefiting from any of my content
i would love to hear about your success story
please share it in the link down below